a new Dragon Ball series has finally
been announced and with its unveiling
the unthinkable has happened a tidal
wave of disagreement and arguing has
cascad over almost every social
imaginable some for justifiable reasons
and others not so much which is why over
the last week we've decided to troll
through the darkest slimiest crevices of
Twitter Tik Tok and even Facebook yes
people still use that shut up and
through doing so we've composed a list
of the most common concerns expressed to
examine their merits all the while we
transform some of the most iconic scenes
from Dragon Ball Z and Dragon Ball super
into DA's new style and vice versa I
suggested I should start this video off
by redrawing the cover art of volume one
of Dragon Ball into Diamond Style you
know I thought it'd be cute and Lord let
me tell you this was way more work than
I thought it would be drawing that
Dragon was a freaking oh hey look I'm
complaining too maybe dond does make
folks complain more oh well a lot of
negative outcry has led to the most
prevalent and surface level criticism to
be that of Dragon Ball daa is
effectively just Dragon Ball GT 2.0 and
today we're here to tell you that that's
just
[Music]
silly all right so this is our character
select screen it's randomized and
whoever it lands on has to redraw this
image into the style of Dragon Ball dier
and oh it's Trev and he's redrawing
Super Saiyan 4 Goku into DA's style all
right so because this is a video
effectively defending DA's right to
exist there will no doubt be folks out
there that will be saying I'm deep
throwing the copium pipe way too
enthusiastically right now but in
reality my position isn't that I think
da is going to be good necessarily just
that we don't have enough information to
make any definitive judgments per se and
the most common criticism everyone
thought of when they saw the trailer has
to be criticism one this is GT 2.0 I
thought it and don't you dare lie you
thought it too everyone's saying it and
it's the number one most thumbed up
comment under the trailer right now
check it out also nice comment jbans 981
it's funny you deserve those
37,000 likes also uh how about you smash
a like button so maybe J beans uh
acknowledges me despite this being the
most common complaint I've seen online
and despite me going on the record and
criticizing Dragon Ball GT story
extensively Dragon Ball daa isn't Dragon
Ball GT unsurprisingly there are of
course surface level similarities not
the least of which being the return of
Kid Goku to the fry with the premise of
exploring other worlds as the trailer
teases however to suggest that this is
GT 2.0 is exceptionally reductionist and
honestly kind of feels like something my
grandmother might have said at Christmas
she'd be all like here you go Mark
there's that game you were looking for
and then proceeds to hand me Spider-Man
2 for the PlayStation 2 instead of
Spider-Man 2 for the PlayStation 5 like
I asked both our sequels with Spider-Man
in the lead but very different games
with very different stories and honestly
even outside of that I think the notion
that this is GT2 is silly to begin with
the idea that GT was just simply Kid
Goku in space and nothing else
completely misses the point of well so
many things that it fundamentally
misunderstands fiction I mean is the
Androids Arc of Dragon Ball Z just
Terminator 2 2 it is if we foolishly
boil down Terminator 2 to Simply person
travels back in time to stop a
cataclysmic future brought on by robots
programmed to kill a single person but
there are so many more parts to a given
work of fiction than boiling it down to
some madeup distillation the Androids
Arc was influenced by Terminator but it
isn't just rehashing it it is a wholly
new product with loads of its unique
elements and Concepts and from the looks
of it daa is very much shaping up to go
the same way even from the small teaser
trailer we've been shown there's already
a lot of interesting stuff to get
excited about and I'm going to get to
that in just a sec but for now here's
trev's finished drawing look at it in
all all its Majesty I don't know how he
does it next up is oh it's me again and
I'm redrawing this pose Goku struck
during the Saiyan Saga in the style of
Dragon Ball da criticism two who asked
for this where's Morrow now I totally
get wanting a continuation of super but
I think it's kind of important to step
back and remember that the anime has
never been an adaptation of toyot taro's
manga it began as a promo tool for the
anime and then veered off in its own
whenever it fell behind just look at the
black Arc or the tournament of power it
skips over Resurrection F and Broly it's
not a functional Standalone product in
its own right and so while it would be
super cool to see its original arcs like
moral and granola adapted later I think
it makes perfect sense why they've gone
with something new it's what they've
always done heck something new is
certainly what I want but what I do take
issue with is the first part of that
criticism the who asked for this
sentiment in fact there was a whole
video that made the rounds recently on
Twitter and Tik Tok that encapsulated
this exact sentiment perfectly I have
never seen a series be so consistently
disappointing so constantly out of touch
with what its fans want as Dragon Ball
I'll leave the link to the full Tik Tok
in the description but basically the
creator of this video is suggesting that
number one fans know what they want this
might seem like an obviously true and
uncontroversial statement and I'm sure
there are instances where this has been
the case but generally if creators
always did what fans wanted then there
would be so much less Innovation so much
less creativity because consumers can
only want something that they know
already exists and that might sound
confusing but think of it like this if
you rewound the clock to the turn of the
1900s you'd find a world where horses
were the primary mode of transportation
if you were to ask people then why what
sort of improvements they'd want to see
in transport they wouldn't say the car
because that didn't exist yet they'd ask
for Faster Horses now I'm not trying to
suggest that Dragon Ball di is going to
do for anime what the car did for
transportation heck I'm not even saying
that it's going to be necessarily good I
don't know because it isn't out yet what
I am saying is don't be caught asking
for Faster Horses when the possibility
of something new is right around the
corner but that wasn't even the worst
thing I thought that dude said in that
video but before I get to that here's
the finished
piece and next up to draw is Trev again
and this time he's drawing Super Saiyan
blue Goku in da style so like I was
saying in that Viral Tik Tok he points
out that other popular fan Creations
have managed to capture what he thinks
all fans want and even goes on to say
quote I'm so thoroughly convinced that
Toriyama doesn't understand why Dragon
Ball Z is popular everyone loves seeing
their favorite characters transform and
take on new exciting forms now look as
someone who makes content surrounding
Dragon Ball online and is exposed to all
sorts of points of view I can admit
there's certainly a percentage of dragon
Ball's fan base that's there for the
fights and the buff aliens throwing
lights at each other it's certainly a
prominent element of the show there's no
denying that but to suggest that's what
everyone likes is a little misguided but
my biggest issue with this quote from
this quote fan is that it implies that
Tori doesn't know what Dragon Ball is so
let me be 100% clear here Toriyama knows
exactly what Dragon Ball is and always
has we've seen outstanding fan
animations like Legend a Dragon Ball
tale Deliverance or popular fan mangas
like Dragon Ball Multiverse and while
there might be an audience for that sort
of story they are importantly not Dragon
Ball and I'm saying that as someone who
supported the patreon of Legend the guy
who led that project is an incredible
Creator and should be proud but he'd
never say he knows Dragon Ball better
than Akira torama these creations put a
real emphasis on action spectacle and
while Dragon Ball is absolutely beloved
for its fights it's not the sole reason
I think the majority of us love this
series we love its world its characters
and the stories surrounding them that
give these iconic fights the emotional
gravitas that has stuck with us all
these years the way Toriyama weaves
comedy drama and breathtaking action is
spectacular and we've seen through his
work outside of Dragon Ball that he's
still more than capable of producing
incredible Adventure Vibes and that's
important but first let's move on to the
next drawing Trev absolutely killed this
Super Saiyan blue Goku in the diam
style and next up to draw is it's AJ and
he will be transforming this close-up
from the trailer of Kid Goku into an
adult version in the style of DA's
character designer katsuyoshi nakatsuru
and yes yes for those wondering the meme
is not dead AJ is still drawing these
with a mouse even though he has a
drawing tablet with a stylus 3 ft from
him bully this man so on the topic of
Adventure and Dragon Ball it brings me
to criticism number three this chibi
dragon ball is going to be for babies
now I feel like this will be a rebuttal
that will fall on deaf ears but here it
goes anyway you're entitled to not like
the aesthetic for your own individual
reason I can't dispute how you feel but
just because a new Dragon Ball series is
led by Juvenile characters doesn't mean
the series will be bere of serious or
action-packed moments I mean like are we
really going to sit here and act like
classic Dragon Ball doesn't exist Dragon
Ball was filled with kids and yet played
host to some of the most Savage tragic
emotional and action-packed moments in
the series one of the main Inspirations
behind Dragon Ball Diamond would be that
of RPGs and therefore will carry with it
a lot of progression elements
Transformations are cool and giant
Universal clashes have certainly become
part of modern Dragon Ball's image but I
think there's a problem with that
there's not really much room left to
explore when that's the scope of your
fair the scope of the battles became so
huge that they almost became parodies of
themselves in super how long have we
spent hearing time and again outcries
from the Dragon Ball Phantom that they
want to return to more grounded martial
arts based strategic combat and
choreography rather than just random
Transformations and beam struggles and
here we are finally getting that not to
harp on this for too long but have you
seen Dragon Ball that show was filled
with some of the most fun show stoly
creative action in the history of the
franchise Goku blasted a Kamehameha out
of his feet the final double knockout
kick between Goku and Jackie Tron in the
finals of the ten kichi buai is one of
the sickest things in the the history of
existence we really are getting a lot of
what we wanted here in terms of grounded
action and I feel like that is worthy of
Praise rather than outrage and with that
it brings us to the end of AJ's redraw I
think he really managed to capture the
designer of this series and aged up Goku
accurately next up is it's Trev again
man Trev really is carrying this video
so far isn't he but hey I'm not
complaining he is going to be redrawing
this image of Goku with his noo or power
pole staff into the style of adult Goku
from Dr Dragon Ball GT and while he does
so I'll be discussing criticism Number
Four Dragon Ball butt babies what is
this Coco melon this is probably the
common complaint that I think is the
most purposely misrepresentative of the
bunch over and over now I've seen people
post about daa as if everyone has been
shrunk down to babies and every single
time they show the shot of Goten and
Trunks as babies but like did we watch
the same teaser trailer they are the
only babies of the the bunch obviously
because they're younger than everyone
before the wish literally everyone else
has been transformed not to babies to
kids with that said however I do find it
funny that for years we've been waiting
for Goten and Trunks to finally be
physically aged up to look more mature
and just as they do it Toriyama makes
them younger than we've ever seen them
well except for trunks we've actually
seen baby trunks before shout out to the
cell Saga and again I don't want to
disparage anyone's personal preference
it is totally fine to prefer fights of
ult Goku and Co over the an original
Dragon Ball but what we are getting with
da is clearly not Dragon Ball Rugrats
Edition it is a show that for the series
40th anniversary hearkens back
intentionally to the days of the
original Dragon Ball the days of
mercenary to pip pie and ten shinhan and
Demon King Piccolo days of the Neo and
the nimbus cloud and everything in the
early world that truly felt well magic
all with a modern host of extremely
talented animators desperate to bring
this celebration to life and while the
production anime clearly looks fantastic
something that has gotten some flak here
and there has been criticism number five
Toriyama aged Goku up because he was
easier to draw in fights now the fights
are going to be bad because kids are
harder to draw in fights granted this is
a much more Niche criticism but I have
seen it out there and to be clear there
is some truth to this too but like most
of these criticisms I think it's missing
a crucial point it's true that during
Dragon Ball's early serialization air
torama expressed that kid Goku's St
proportions were a limiting factor when
it came to the action sequences and so
when the 23rd tenai ichai rolled around
he did what was very uncommon at the
time by fundamentally changing the
aesthetic of his main character in the
case of Goku it was to age him into an
adult thus granting him longer limbs
which he could more easily draw Dynamic
poses with however this does not mean
that diamond will suffer the same
limiting factors as early Dragon Ball
did simply because Dragon Ball da isn't
drawn in the style of classic Toriyama
but instead his modern style you'll
notice that in super or even toriyama's
own drawings for the characters over the
last 10 plus years there's been a
consistent push towards a more slender
style of physical form this entirely
remedies the issues he encountered in
early Dragon Ball no more stubby limbs
now we have slender more easily
pronounceable Limbs and what's more is
because these designs are very refined
they end up translating into animation
really well as you've no doubt seen in
the trailer and as we will no doubt see
when the series is ultimately released
but before we move on let's take a look
at this redraw Trev totally crushed this
one and did a fantastically faithful job
in the process next up on the drawing
block is it's yours truly and I'll be
redrawing this image of Goku powering up
his Super Saiyan God form from Dragon
Ball super into DA's art style with kid
Goku all the while I tackle criticism
number six the action won't be as good
it's going to be a slice of life I miss
Z Arrow raw action and animation this
show isn't going to be a slice of life
story Slice of Life for those that don't
know would be the sort of Misadventures
Goku and Piccolo might get up to when
looking after pan for the day they are
low stakes and a slice of everyday life
and you know what super had that exact
episode this is to say dragon ball is
normally a mix between much lighter fair
and more intense battles you need to
have the light to make the darker
moments shine prominently having a
series with just action and intense
serious moments creates a very WOTE and
boring atmosphere to paraphrase Syndrome
from The Incredibles if everything is
intense then nothing is the story will
likely present a combination of humorous
light material mixed with action and
dramatic moments like Dragon Ball Z like
Dragon Ball super and like Dragon Ball
super were Broly bit and I'm certain the
art style will reflect this in the same
way action animators like yuya Takahashi
were tasked with the action sequences in
the Broly film so too will they be
offered the chance to work on the action
of Da and present it in the best way
possible again at the end of the day
this is a story written by Akira
Toriyama for the 40th anniversary of the
series one that intentionally hearkens
back to the Golden Age of Dragon Ball
the name might have been a placeholder
in the past but to me it's clear that
there's a concerted effort to try to
reignite that magic which catapulted
dragon ball into the mainstream one that
didn't rely on Transformations or flashy
energy blasts one designed thoughtfully
around Adventure combat and a love for
comedy but yeah that's a that's my da
Goku as a Super Saiyan
God next up is trevan and he's redrawing
this shot of shin kibito and Goku into
the style of Dragon Ball super and
that's a appropriate because this series
will not have the same problems Dragon
Ball super made headlines all over the
world with it has been made very clear
internally that toi does not want to
repeat the sins of Dragon Ball Super's
past and as a result the animation
overall production will have tremendous
polish in addition to gaining an
All-Star cast of impressive animators da
2 has shed some of the baggage that
impeded Super's production gone are the
rigid and overly shiny designs that
plagued Dragon Ball super gone are the
horribly saturated colors and lack of
art Direction everything has been
revamped for this series and it shows in
the trailer alone stacks of atmosphere
great animation great color work it's
it's awesome furthermore unlike any
other show in Dragon Ball's history this
series isn't being produced like your
average TV series it's not beginning
with only a few episodes finished and
adhering to a strict schedule thereafter
Instead This is being given a production
timeline Aid into a movie with 2 years
of the animation phase taking place
before it even starts airing this in
tandem with the impressive team behind
it as well as Akira toriyama's intimate
involvement will no doubt yield an
addition to the franchise that if
nothing else will be stunning and
distinctly Dragon Ball personally I
cannot wait to see it because I don't
know about you but this image despite
being well crafted and faithful to
Super's aesthetic it is not a look I
want to return to if we can help it
while Trev is closing us off and
redrawing this kid Goku falling from the
lookout as an adult I'd like to bring
this video full circle and touch on the
growing misunderstanding that da is
simply GT 2.0 once again I want to touch
on this by highlighting why I think GT
was so widely disliked and it wasn't
because Goku was a kid going on
adventures classic Dragon Ball did all
of that and is widely considered one of
the best stretches of the series in my
view GT was lacking because the stories
which made up the first Arc were were
largely uninteresting and more than that
it felt as though the team behind the
series itself didn't fully believe in or
have a solid vision for the story they
wanted to tell and this is reflected in
other areas of the story too bringing
back 17 wasn't a great decision and
ultimately felt vapid the shadow Dragons
Were a cool concept but the execution
was exceptionally uninspired and boring
from an art standpoint compared to the
rest of the series on average the
storyboards for the action felt
extremely lacking and outside of the
main theme which slapped and still slaps
the score for this series just wasn't it
hell the whole adventures in space with
Goku business really barely lasted the
first Arc of GT the concept of a grand
Adventure that could expand on lore and
introduce new characters is actually
freaking awesome and to discredit daa
based on something so superficial seems
exceptionally crude and well reductive
Dragon Ball da could be just as dull and
repetitive as Dragon Ball GT but and
this is genuinely important the series
unlike GT has immense Toriyama
involvement beyond anything we've seen
before his involvement with daa doesn't
end with designs like it did for
Dragonball GT he's writing the entire
story start to finish he's even
involving himself in looking at boards
and animations something he's never
really done before meaning the words and
the actions of everything we will see
will have that Toriyama touch more than
GT more than Dragon Ball super and even
more than Dragon Ball super Broly will
it be good I honestly cannot say but I'm
certainly not going to write it off
until I see it for myself there's too
much promise here for me to do something
like that and ultimately that's what I
hope this video makes clear to you too
it may not be what you personally wanted
heck I certainly didn't think this was
the direction they were going to go but
the little information we do have so far
paints a picture of of something that at
the very least should be an exciting
Endeavor to give a fair shot to next
year thanks for
[Music]
watching